when you sell an artist on your
it isn't even really about selling an
artist on something it's it's what we're
hearing in the world i mean that there's
there's been a the zeitgeist right now
nft metaverse right the most overused
term in the in the history of the last
12 months
it's everywhere right so what is the
metaverse
uh it's no
i mean i i think it's different for
everybody my personal perspective i
really think about it in a very literal
way i think of um as simple as roblox
right where your kids are running around
with avatars and they're buying items
in-game that then they can be
represented that's a very narrow
definition but that's how i kind of like
to segment things right but you can say
it's basically everything living in this
digital value
layer so but that's what you know my my
interpretation of all this is you know
everything has value yes you know i'm 66
years old uh you know
a pokemon card didn't mean anything to
me you know but i know that people spend
big money uh
i think it was logan didn't he get
ripped off for like 13 million yeah yeah
but he he bought he bought uh uh he i
think he spent 1.3 million or 13 million
if anybody knows what it what what it is
it was one two one million 1.3 yeah 1.3
million on a collection of pokemon and
then found out they weren't
legitimate right so that's so that's
exactly what exactly that's what exactly
you could invest in anything you could
invest in a in a classic car right but
then you find out it was rebuilt and
they said this is not the original point
with art i just saw that netflix special
where everyone was buying all that fake
art remember and duping everyone and
they found out later on that it wasn't
the original artist yeah yeah and they
were spending millions and millions of
dollars on these art pieces so with this
so what i'm saying is on them in the
metaverse which are where they exist
where all these blockchains exist
you're giving a um
an image or a sound
to
uh
you're able to tr because of blockchain
technology right we're able to trace
ownership and with that full
transparency for any digital asset so
that could be for a ticket stub right so
that we we could kind of cut out like
that that's just like lowest hanging
fruit right where it's a ticket stub and
when it goes to you know scalpers like
this kind of solves that issue as well
where we can actually track ownership
and you're not buying fake tickets
that's the best
explanation i've heard right so i have i
i have friends who've been duped so many
times in concerts and they bought it
wasn't a real ticket so that's why i
think that this sounds very
kind of
forward thinking right now sure but i
think it is it is a technology that's
coming so fast where it's going to be
the norm yes and this is how we're going
to collect our art where we're going to
collect our knowledge where we're going
to collect our music where we're going
to collect culture it goes beyond
that go ahead
no yeah and i i think also identity too
right like
eventually a lot of our assets or a lot
of our value is gonna shift from like
physical into the digital and then the
digital world is gonna become more and
more like i would say consuming our
lives and then so like the assets and we
make up what an asset is yes you know
we've always even though this sounds
like it's star wars and it's it's beyond
this you know
people feel good because they have a
brand
patch on on a shirt you could buy a
black shirt but if your shirt says gucci
on it
we said
we made that up that that becomes more
valuable this is kind of the same thing
that's exactly it's exactly what i mean
you know where okay we can go around and
dress how we dress and express ourselves
but then you go into like a twitter
group or a group dm or any or like
direct message right and you know you we
can't show off our shoes we can't show
off our cars we can't show off our
houses or whatever but we can show off
what we call a pfp which is a profile
picture and that kind of becomes the
embodiment of your online persona so i
think that's where one part and i think
that's why pfp is what that's why we see
the beavers um and uh i forgot who else
you guys brought up of buying rapes
eminem jimmy fallon paris hilton right
so they buy these board apes they're
online entities that's the flex there
right you know what i mean so and it all
depends on what room you're in because
if you're in a room if you're in a
conference room where people want
rolexes then you're not going to roll up
in a seiko right and same thing with a a
conference call that is online
you know you if if you're trying to flex
on that kind of nature you know i mean
you're gonna even even with our apple
watches we're displaying our pfps on our
watches you know what i mean just to
kind of show pfp standing for um profile
picture profile picture okay i'm not
down no no
we're gonna have to get you a pfp is
what we're gonna have to do better than
an std
[Music]
you